et d'ailleurs on va en parler avec andré
richelieu professeur expert en marketing
du sport à l'école de gestion de l'uqam
bonjour monsieur richelieu bon je me
supporter
merci d'être avec nous pour nous parler
de ce retour du hockey
alors là les amateurs d'art qui sont
excités enfin on pourra revoir des
matches mais est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une
bonne idée ce retour au jura pleine
pandémie l'un deux côtés on sait très
peu de choses de ce virus de cette
pandémie qui touche tout le monde je
disais un peu plus tôt à votre
collaboratrice que ce virus ne frappe à
la porte en demandant s'ils pouvaient
entrer dans l'organisme personne n'est
immunisé
c'est un virus qui a des conséquences et
des enjeux sanitaires économiques et
politiques qui vont toucher
bien entendu le sport professionnel qui
va bouleverser le sport professionnel
dans son fonctionnement dans la façon de
consommer le produit sportif et
aujourd'hui ce retour au jeu
bien qu'on ne puisse pas arrêté de vivre
m'inquiète parce qu'à mon avis mieux
vaut être prudent que de céder au
relâchement surtout au milieu d'une
pandémie pour laquelle il n'y a toujours
aucun vaccin
mon amie ma place quand même du côté la
ligue nationale b rock et des devil
bulls est pas suffisant selon vous
écoutez je ne suis pas médecin je ne
vais pas prétendre l'être mais je ne
crois pas qu'il faille être un prix
nobel de médecine pour faire preuve de
bon sens que ce soit des billets ville
pull ou que les équipes voyage d'une
ville de ville à ville
le risque est toujours présente et ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que on court un
risque énorme pour la santé publique
pour revenir au jeu non pas pour le
sport mais bien plutôt pour des
considérations financières pécuniaires
et sauver ce qui peut l'être en termes
de droits de retransmission télé et
streaming mais aussi en termes de
commandites c'est là que se joue en
salle qui est décision de retour au jeu
que ce soit en amérique du nord ou en
europe avec le football soccer comme on
l'a vu il ya quelques semaines mais sur
les lieux dans le fond c'est une
décision d'ailleurs ce retour au jeu ce
une décision avant toute décision
financière
on veut surtout limiter les pertes
actuellement tout à fait je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres si vous
permettez
selon keith insider en 2018 les chiffres
que l'on a les plus récents le marché
mondial du sport et tout son écosystème
représentait près de 500 milliards de
dollars américains si on regarde les
droits de retransmission télé et
streaming sportsnet paix 433 millions de
dollars canadiens par année pour ses
droits une sur 12 ans on est à peu près
au milieu de l'entente et quebecor via
tva sports p 100 millions de dollars
canadiens par année uniquement pour les
droits de retransmission
donc si on regarde ce qui s'est passé en
europe avec les pertes qui était dû au
fait que des matches n'avaient pas été
présentées ou présentés en retard on
peut s'attendre une fois qu'on aura
fermé les livres de ces séries
éliminatoires jusqu'où iront elles ça
c'est une autre paire de manche à des
pertes de dizaines de millions de
dollars voire une centaine de millions
de dollars pour la ligue mais aussi les
joueurs puisque dans le contexte d'un
partage des revenus
vous avez 50 50 pour cent un partage
d'ordre sein de 50 50 entre les joueurs
et les équipes donc les deux parties
veulent finir la saison malgré le
contexte pour éviter d'être impacté
négativement que ce soit cette année
mais aussi l'année prochaine sur le
plafond salarial par exemple puisque ce
plafond salarial est déterminé par
l'ensemble des revenus générés par la
ligue
ouais c'est là qu'on verrait à
l'actionnement donc une baisse de
salaire le pauvre paul eluard
vous avez parlé aussi donc diffusable et
je lisais aussi dans un papier de la
cible ici alors les billets alors les
billets qui sont payés évidemment par
les partisans
ça peut représenter actuellement donc
les prochains matches des pertes entre
150 jusqu'à 200 millions de dollars
seulement à vendre de billets là alors
c'est toute la chaîne finalement qui
perd de l'argent
oui c'est tout année d'écosystèmes votre
point est extrêmement important puisque
les matchs vont être présentés mais sans
spectateurs donc en termes de revenus
vous perdez la billetterie qui pouvait
représenter par exemple pour les
caennais montréal jusqu'à 2.5 millions
de dollars par match des séries
vous perdez aussi les revenus des
concessions alimentaires souvenirs etc
et n'oublions pas non plus tout ce qui
touche des produits dérivés selon price
water avant la pandémie
le marché des produits dérivés vous
savez ces répliques de chandails des 20
milliards de dollars américains par
année à l'échelle de la planète
donc c'est beaucoup d'argent qui
risquent d'être perdus et ce qu'on veut
faire c'est limité la casse père
n'étaient pas l'expression on est à la
télévision je vais quand même préservé
un sens du décorum
il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu et ce qui
est inquiétant eu pourquoi je disais que
c'est inquiétant c'est que on ne sait
pas ce qui va se passer on espère le
meilleur mais advenant qu'il y ait un
nouveau foyer qu'il y ait des
contaminations et on l'a vu au baseball
cela peut arriver au qui malgré ses
bulles que l'on a créé à toronto et
edmonton
c'est que tous les efforts qu'on a faits
au temps du confinement risquent d'être
perdus pour un une partie très minime de
la population des propriétaires
milliardaires parfois très endettés mais
milliardaire et des joueurs
millionnaires qui a frappé dans une
rondelle ou dans un ballon et les gens
ensuite ont tout à fait le droit de se
demander mais pourquoi ce relâchement
alors qu'on nous demande de rester
vigilant et il faut l'être car la
situation est grave donc je dirais que
c'est un peu prématuré on confond
vitesse et précipitation et autant
j'aime le sport autant en tant que
professeur en tant que scientifique
j'ai énormément de craintes quant à ce
retour au jeu primature et du sport
professionnel en amérique du nord par le
modèle vous en avez parlé aussi donc du
modèle actuellement ce qu'on envoie donc
100 spectateurs
si c'est pas viable ça pour l'avenir le
plomb c'est paul lorsqu'on aura un
vaccin pour la prochaine saison
écoutez vous touchez un point essentiel
parce que ça va cette pandémie la touche
de fonction dans les cinq ans plus tôt
possible
donnez moi c'est la seconde et je suis
c'est de vous en donner le plus dans les
têtes et que vous accordez donc le
fonctionnement des lic mais ça inclut
également la survie de certaines équipes
qui vacille et déjà avant la pandémie
penser aux sénateurs d'ottawa qui
s'était aliéné les partisans au point où
à ottawa gatineau les gens qui ont tombé
dans l'indifférence vis à vis des
sénateurs ça c'est une chose les modes
de consommation sportives ont aussi
changé et finalement des stades est
stable sur le chantier ça va être
terminé
merci merci beaucoup monsieur riches